you're a nurturer you've like taken care
of people your whole life yes three days
a week anyway because i work out on 14th
street so you and i we're just going to
make this a thing well and you're a
nurturer you've like taken care of
people your whole life yes
i i would are we crying today we might
okay it happened here on this show
because it's life right and we don't try
to pretend it's anything but what it is
but you know um i just really admire
your journey and i just want to be a
part of your crew oh thank you so much
well you know
it's i'm gonna give you guys a little
cliff notes of millie pierce really
quickly so at the age of 25 i lost my
mom the colon cancer
and i had to take care of my four
brothers and sisters two of them were
autistic so we my life has been full of
ups and downs but i say it's most
important that you do the pivot like you
know we all get sad we lose people i'm
pretty sure throughout the last two
years like everybody has been affected
by something somehow some way whether
they knew somebody that lost someone
where they lost somebody personally but
you know um it's all about you got to
pick yourself up you got to continue to
grow go so even in 2019 i lost my
restaurant right before the pandemic
that's right that was illegal gasping
work done in the building so i lost my
business and it was like you just got to
keep going so
when the pandemic happened you know i
caught covet early on and this was
during the time of like no mass we
really didn't know what was going on i
agree we just knew when you lost a sense
of taste and smell that wasn't a good
thing oh god but you know as i got
better you know when you started to open
up a little bit we started to feed
essential workers and essential workers
it was just like you know we wanted to
be able to help people and feed people
because everything was closed right that
captioning not available
and then
i get this message like you know i
started to cook and they can just try to
be happier and help people
and i get this call from chip and joann
and i like you know what
we're just inspired by anything you do
let's do something and i was like okay
well let's do something and that's how a
chef's guide to soul food came about i
love this story so much
now millie
one of the things we're going to tackle
today is something that i think
so many people
are in the dilemma of is leftovers and i
heard you say you can
and will reinvent them so there is no
food waste and i love this particular
recipe
um and i'm like
teach us i'm in your car you are the
driver
teach us millie what are we doing
absolutely so people oftentimes say you
know what i don't eat leftovers i'm a
big leftover girl i just feel like you
know it tastes better next day but some
people they just don't care for it but
we live in a society where we shouldn't
be throwing away food right so this
recipe is my magnolia macaroni and
cheese and i um you mean this right here
yes i want you to taste that because i
heard that that's your favorite thing is
macaroni and cheese it's um my number
one food on planet earth
um
is i'm salivating yep just going for it
see there you go that's right that's yep
that's that's what we're looking for
haha millie keep going so so it's really
good so what we're going to do is we're
going to take this macaroni and cheese
and we're gonna repurpose it something
else so we're gonna make
a macaroni and cheese waffle you know
you get that crispy crunchy with a
little bit more cheese so you get that
ooey gooey moment of it but then
oftentimes we have leftover protein so
sometimes people cook protein they may
overcook it it may be dried out so in
this pan we have a tablespoon of salt or
so of olive oil we have some caramelized
onions and then we're going to add some
garlic i love garlic this is about six
cloves but add more or less if you like
we're also going to bring some brisket
back we're going to bring some whisk it
backslide so we already have some
chopped brisket here
and we're going to dump this in
had that and it smells good already and
because you know i love soul food and
southern food because their soul food
and southern food are different there
are seven cuisines to southern food but
we're going to take a little cajun
seasoning we're going to add a little
bit more spice to it how much milly as
much as like as you i do a big pinch i'm
i'm not subtle about anything so
and and when i make my cajun seasoning i
do it salt free to your point is you're
not subtle about it so it gives you all
that flavor but you're not making it
salty because don't forget we already
cooked this already and it has salt in
the meat right and then so we have this
going and then we're going to add some
stock
yeah because brisket can get dry
and we're just dehydrating is this stock
this is stock this is beef stock we're
using we're adding flavor upon flavor if
you have chicken stock if you have like
some beef bouillon whatever it is you
got vegetable stock or you can even add
water see this is what i mean about
reconstituting you are bringing this
into not just back to life but a new
life absolutely and it'll be equally
delicious and then we added some stock
and now we're going to add some barbecue
sauce oh okay
mm-hmm
i heard somebody say mmm
i
i mean oh god i love barbecue sauce i
love barbecue sauce and if you make
barbecue sauce feel free to use a jarred
barbecue sauce if you like it's all
about making things your own and that's
one thing i like about soul food so much
you make things your own and i show you
guys how i make cornbread and macaroni
and cheese and everything in my magnolia
project i put cinnamon in my cornbread
but if you don't like cinnamon don't use
cinnamon it's all about showing you the
technique on the reason why i do things
and it's most important that we're
telling a story and that's the one thing
i like about the magnolia network they
got us a whole bunch of us storytellers
together and we're able to tell stories
you know yes absolutely now how long do
i want to cook the liquid out
um
how long would you suggest that i let
this go male 1 we'll let this go for
about 10 or 15 minutes you're going to
constantly start all right i'm glad i
asked i would have pulled this off and
had something kind of drippy and i would
not have thought to leave it in there
for 10 or 15. i'm really glad i actually
have rehydrating it if you overcook it
and then it can pull together a little
bit more so you can have like this
pulled brisket but most importantly you
want to rehydrate it you want the flavor
and you want it to be very moist see
this is why i don't know what i'm doing
[Music]
you